ん
1件
こんにちははじめ社長です
東京で新疆借りてから僕の生活は一変した
きらびやかな街東京での生活は本当に最高でご飯はおいしいしおうちもこんなに
エレガント
国や東京にいる時はいつも棋風このような生活を満喫してるのさ
あっはっはっ
あっはっは
つがー
今日は外れそうです投稿
違うんです違うでじゃああー良いよ想いだけはじめ俺は何をしに東京に来たのは
思い出せ
出しか2月には高いしコーディネーターさんに家のコーディネートしてもらってメッツ
高級感あふれる彼の変になったんですけど
ちがー
は根本的に違うんですよ手術気づいたんですけどもこの部屋
動画とれねーこの部屋堂アトレないんですよ全然感づいてだけど俺ははっきりと今回
分かりましたこの日は動画撮れませんなんなんこのヘラーやも白ばかり今
コーディネーターと批判しているわけではありません前文ではとても素敵なお部屋なん
で高級感未来か素晴らしい家具の品々完璧な上だと思うんですけどもこの部屋じゃ動画
は撮れ
どれどれ
動画
朝礼俺思い出したんです
俺ユーチューバーだった確かにインテリアコーディネーターさんにヤバイ感じのをニャ
にしてくださいてもらって行ってもらったんですけどもやばすぎて動画が撮れないこと
に気づいたんです一応もう一つの部屋で編集とかやってるんですけどそっちは俺の部屋
っぽいんですよこれをこんな感じですよ
こっちは何かユーチューバーぽいっていうか何か僕っぽいと思うんですけども
あっちこの部屋に関してはに願寺
で動画が取りにくい目立つものが多すぎるしなんかも
この部屋で動画とると思わないんですよここここ座った時点でも俺スマブラしちゃうし
この s 邪魔だし足方も最初に直この全ても無駄なんですよも所沢のためのフェア
みたいになってて
じゃあ君がいいならいいけどこんな文仕切りとかあるんですよ俺のイメージだと
ここ押し切ってなら編集やにして2名で撮影しようと思ったんですよ
同8世が音あそび心マン大好き
動画実というわけで今日はもう華々しい東京生活は開きました
それだけに何かボンドんの生活っぽい感じだしてたんですけどもそんなの俺だけで今日
はこのなりティの部屋を動画撮影できるレベルに戻そうと思います謎の数が多すぎてや
いい意味でですよインテリアコーディネーターさんありがとうございますいい意味で
マゾの数が多すぎ
てなんか小野田うざすぎる別れてないんでしっかりと
youtube 元に戻させていただきますちょっと悪いポイントから上げていき
ましょうお部屋が割れてるわけじゃなくて中中盤的にはれってポイントですね
いきます
はいまず照明ですねナナベってるんですよこっちも
でもこれ俺に感謝も頭ぶつかっちゃうんですよねしっかり部屋購入させてあげたいです
ねこれだって動画でできることはあんまりないと思うんですよ
館の壁ねもうねがチカチカするんですけどめっちゃ3 d これもちょっと何とかし
たいですね高さが色々物を動かしたりして
この一番大きい部屋をもっと有効活用
たいと思ってるんで早速改造していきたいと思いますではなんだこの使われてところ猿
にはここは編集用に改造していきますこのかな人がちょっとまずどうすれこれを業者
考えようかなんです
動画します
ねどうするって
て側の人壁に穴を開けだぞん
とっ
[音楽]
先生は置く場所ないで戻しますとりあえず俺に気付いたもの多すぎるからいけないもの
を
[音楽]
片付けようっ
作成変更ですしキーなどはなんですよこういう
レッジオドアこういうのあるんですけども作れますね1のポイントが気になるんでこう
偏執病山楽荘
ここをそういうちょっとはのいわゆる全部が50階まで娯楽の部屋だったんでそれは
全部こっちに集めます
[音楽]
はいというわけで無事無駄土田の仕切りで作れる日はこんな感じになりました
ん
結構凝縮しましたねディスプレイとスイッチぐらいでしか遊ばないんでこんなけ
スペースがあればまあいいんじゃないかなっていう感じです
狭いかはいというわけであとはこのメインルームも一家に動画ように仕上げるかですね
個人的には彼とウェイなんでここバックで取れると一番声だしやすいんでここでも全部
コツ2回動かしたでしょうか
re ん
音の良い
[音楽]
ん
ああああああ
入った婦人部のツアー
箱だけで持ったこの前から制圧バエ畑やボークスぺりこない考えていきたい
はい結構整いました
これで
字型前だこれこれを噂になったっ
[音楽]
ポッを
おぉっ
まあ
これが限界ですね
どうアーマーももよし
多分平行になりましたこっちも変更になりましたこれ以上高くできないっぽいんでこれ
が限界ですはいというわけで第二撮影スペースができてきました
うスロに今まで高くとも全部個まとめてそれでこっちをギュッと揚げた感じですここが
撮影スペースにしたいですねまぁただもう
食べなぁ亀がなせ目立つ的なんですけどなにこれ
とれるんだここに昼はイジョヴィどうも休みだなこの背景
確かにオサレなんですよどうかだと思う俺より後ろの方が目立ってるんですよこれ
香典は泣いてるからいいよね多分やって
1回とよっ
きただろうう
したきちゃったっていい絶対なぁこれだけの病院なにこれ絶対ダメっすじゃあ arkz
だってどうやってやった翻訳にヤバイはああっ夏そうな to do
を生きるだ俺
[拍手]
re ああああああ
はぁう
ああああああ
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
[音楽]
nd
やったやって合っちゃった武芸
大丈夫まずねまずは金が入ってこういうもんですからうって言って部分とか仕方ないん
ですけれどもそれ以外は結構綺麗に撮れたんじゃないかなと思いますはいというわけで
どうでしょう最初に比べるとかなり靴をずっとその
成金感がきれいだと思いますこれがユーチューバーです僕品
は机の上で動画撮りたい人なんですけども位は机が無いんで
現状件増の素材で準備できる俺の撮影場所がこちらです
あっはぁ
[音楽]
blh r
あのいろいろ壁があるけど一番まともな形がこのヒーローのいちでしたねが机とかおい
てちゃんとしたセットで撮りたいと思うんで
申しますお待ち音とれる東京成金生が昨今ですではまた